des fumées temps sur la côte ouest des
inondations en Chine et en Europe des
températures extrêmes partout sur la
planète le dérèglement climatique est
plus que jamais à l'ordre du jour et
de responsable
pour déterminer la nouvelle
depuis 2014
pour mieux comprendre en fait
sur
les objectifs à atteindre
parvenir mon c'est déjà là-bas sera
haute on estime que depuis les 50
dernières années des événements
climatiques extrêmes représente 50 % des
désastres 45 % de décès et 74 % des
pertes économique à l'échelle mondiale
pour annoncer cette tendance Claude il
faudra au moins atteindre l'objectif de
l'accord de Paris soit une hausse
maximale de 1,5 degrés la température
mondiale le Paris
est-ce qu'on travaille pour que c' est
seul, 5 ans mode de laisser-aller
énergétique des rapports du GIEC ne sont
pas réservées aux experts dans le passé
ils ont souvent servi de tremplin ou
mouvement populaire c'est grave là on
servit en fait pour parler davantage des
questions scientifiques et comment on
devait en fait mieux utiliser la science
que déposerai le groupe
intergouvernementale sur l'évolution du
climat de 1988 is normal grande 1re S du
Canada Montréal